WIL: Mike, Matt,
congratulations.
You've made it to the next phase
in this operation, which means
we're sending you back
to your home forges
to recreate this iconic
weapon, the United
States Air Force
non-commissioned officer's
sword.
[sigh]
You'll have four days
at your home forges
in which to complete
this challenge.
At the end of four days, you'll
return and present your swords
to our panel of expert judges.
And after they've put
them through the paces,
they'll move one of you
one to our final Battle
of the Branches competition.
You also need to make a
scabbard for the sword.
Oh, man.
I'm just messing with you.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
Good luck, brother.
MIKE: It's day one.
It feels great to be back
here in my home forge.
For this blade, I'm going
to be using Damascus.
And I'm going to try to put
in a twist just for fun.
A lot of Air Force ties in
how I live my life day-to-day,
and this challenge
was no exception.
There's a lot of firsts
for me on this blade.
I've never done
Damascus this long.
I've never heat-treated
anything this long.
I've never made a
crossguard like this before.
It's going to be a
bit stressful for me.
None of my welds popped, so
at least it's a solid billet.
So we won't know for sure
until we're grinding into it,
but I'm fairly certain it
was a successful twist.
I don't think we
have any inclusions.
I think it's going
to look pretty good.
So I've got 16 layers
now in this billet.
I've got it drawn out enough.
I can cut it into three sections
and stack it back on itself
for a total of 48 layers.
This is going to be one of
the longest things I've ever
forged, so keeping
it straight might
be a little bit of a
challenge, especially
with the twist in it.
That could cause
some things to warp.
All in all, a solid
finish for day one.
[music playing]
MATT: Now that I'm one
of two [inaudible] left,
I definitely want
to be, you know,
the one that shows
that the Air Force has
what it takes to win the "Forged
in Fire" branches competition.
The plan for today is to draw
the 1084 round stock out.
I'm just going to draw the line
on the floor to give me an idea
of how far I've drawn it out.
To start, the 1084
steel was 20 inches.
I've got to draw it
out to about 35 inches
to get the crossguard, the
handle, and the pommel.
I've still got to draw it
out quite a bit, get it down.
This 27- to 28-inch
sword, it's going to be
interesting keep it straight.
It is at negative 18
outside right now,
so I'm ready to get inside
and turn this forge on.
So yesterday, I got
the blade drawn out.
This morning, we're
going for the quench.
Getting something this long
hot and keeping it straight
is going to be one of my
biggest challenges right now.
Now, I've got a warping issue.
I might be heat
treating it again.
In the back of your mind,
you're always thinking,
did the heat treat not go well?
Quenching two times, we'll have,
you know, bad grain structure.
I have a ton of concerns.
Slight warp, but
at this point, I'm
definitely not quenching again.
MIKE: It's the
morning of day four.
I didn't sleep very well.
I still need to
finish the pommel.
I need to finish the crossguard.
And I haven't even
started the handle yet.
I can tell we're
almost through, though.
Almost there.
I can feel it.
I definitely think
this is a blade
worthy of having me
stand at the Air Force
and go on to the final round.
It is an example of
how I problem-solve,
how I look for solutions,
and how I don't give up.
All right.
That's as good as
we're going to get.
MATT: Day four.
And today, I need to get
the crossguard fitted up,
the handle shape
wrapped with wire,
and then the pommel
assembled as well.
[inaudible]
Looking at the
original NCO sword,
I was trying to figure out
what the best way to make
that wire-wrapped handle was.
Safety wire.
We used that in the military.
I thought that was
good to kind of throw
a little Air Force-ism into it.
It works perfect.
I'm definitely nervous that
I have only one day left.
In the back of your mind,
you're always thinking,
do I have what it takes
to move on to the Battle
of the Branches?
I mean, that's what
it's all about.
That's it.
May the best airman win.
DOUG: All right, airmen.
Now, I'll take your
weapon and deliver
some thrusts and slashes
on this ballistics dummy.
Mike, you're up first.
You ready?
- Absolutely.
Let's do it.
[laughter]
All right, Mike.
It's a very light sword.
Because of that, you
can move with it.
Now, your tip allows
for a nice thrust.
With your edge, it slices.
I can feel every cut in there.
But more importantly,
it will kill.
- Thank you.
- All right, Matt.
Your turn.
You ready, sir?
Yes, sir.
[sigh]
[chuckling]
All right, Matt.
Let's talk about
your blade here.
The edge that you have
here is very sharp.
The point punctures nicely.
And most importantly,
sir, it will kill.
Awesome.
Thank you.
All right.
Next up, the strength test.
For that, we have Ben.
Hello, bladesmiths.
To test the strength and
durability of your swords
as well as their
overall construction,
I'll be bashing them
into this propeller.
Mike, you're up first.
You ready?
No.
[laughter] We're
going to do it anyway.
All right.
[pounding]
[sigh]
[clattering]
Good job.
Oh, my gosh.
Well, Mike, your
blade help up great.
The only issue I have with
it is that I would really
like this pommel to be bigger.
If the pommel were bigger,
it would give me a stop.
But it's got a nice weight.
It's still sharp
as when it started.
Really well done.
Thank you so much.
Matt, you're up.
What are you thinking?
I'm ready.
[pounding]
[clattering]
That's badass.
Well, Matt, your
blade held up great.
It's still sharp.
This is a much heavier sword.
But the biggest issue I have
is with the crossguard in back.
Your crossguard is loose.
It wiggles.
And also, your
wire wrap is loose.
But it's all in one piece.
It did a heck of a
thing on that propeller.
Well done.
Thank you.
BEN: But we're not finished yet.
Next up is the sharpness test.
And for that, I
give you to Doug.
All right, airmen.
To test the edge of your
blade, I'm going to be
cutting across these harnesses.
I'm looking for clean cuts.
Mike, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Let's do it.
Let's do this.
- Good job.
- Right through it.
That was good.
Sharp.
All right, Mike.
Light in flight and sharp enough
to cut through the harness.
It will cut.
Thank you, sir.
Good job.
Thanks, man.
All right, Matt.
Your turn, sir.
You ready?
- Yes, sir.
Damn.
DOUG: All right, Matt.
Let's talk about
your blade here.
It's kind of heavy.
It's so forward in its weight
that on this slash, using
the last six inches,
it just scratched
the back of the harness.
But on the backhand swing, where
it's going all the way through,
it cut the harness.
But your weapon,
sir, it will cut.
Thanks.
Good job, man.
Mike, Matt, the bladesmith
moving forward is Mike.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Matt, first of all,
thank you for your service.
You have a beautiful
sword that did quite well.
But we based our
decision on the fact
that your guard came loose,
the weight of your sword,
and the wire wrapping
is also loose.
That's the reason
we're sending you home.
Yes, sir.
Matt, at this time,
I have to ask you
to please surrender your blade.
MATT (VOICEOVER): I feel
good no matter what.
I mean, I'm glad I made it here.
DOUG: Good job.
Thank you.
I'm proud of myself for sure.
Mike's going to represent
the Air Force well.
He's got a lot of people
rooting for him, me, as well.
And he's a good
bladesmith, so good luck.
Mike, they said you're only
as good as your competition,
and you overcame a
fantastic competitor
to move forward in
this competition
to represent the entire
branch of the Air Force
at our Battle of the
Branches competition.
How do you feel?
It feels amazing.
Please present your
blade to the judges.
MIKE (VOICEOVER):
I can't believe
I'm the Air Force champion.
I'm looking forward to
showing the rest of the DOD
what we've got.
There's a lot of added
pressure moving forward.
Now, I'm competing against
the Army, the Navy,
and the Marine Corps, and
we've got a little bit
of a rivalry going on.
So you better bring it,
because you know I'm going to.